[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم انسي
ابي عاصف الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره من مخيم
جنين ومؤتمر صحفي مرتقب للفصائل بعد
الاقتحام الكبير لقوات الاحتلال
وهذه لقطات مباشره لمعتبر صحفي للرئيس
الاوكراني
في مؤتمر صحفي في العاصمه التشيكيه براج
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد اعلان كتائب القسام مسؤوليتها عن قتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابه حارس امس عمليه
بمستوطنه
حركه حماس تقول ان الهجوم تاكيد لجاهزيه
رد المقاومه في اي مكان على جرائم
الاحتلال الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد مقتل احد
جنوده ويعتقل والدا المنفذ وشقيقه وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي يعلن تسريع خطط بناء
الف ومئه وحده استطانيه قرب موقع العمليه
بعد اشارات من الامين العام للنيتو عن قرب
التوصل لتوافق تركي سويدي
انقره تؤكد تمسكها بضروره ايفاء ستوكهولم
بالتزاماتها في مكافحه الارهاب قبل
الموافقه على انضمامها
نفذت جنود مذكره التفاهم وانه لا يمكن
القيام بالمزيد
بعد ترجيحات بوجوده داخل بيلاروسيا
لوكاشينكو يقول ان مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر
مازال في روسيا الكرملين يقول انه لا
يتعقب بريكوجين ويؤكد التزامه باتفاق
الوساطه البيلاروسي او واشنطن تؤكد انها
ترصد تحركات فاجنر عن كسر
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الهجوم الذي استهدف
مستوطنه كادوميم غرب نابلس واسفر عن مقتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابه حارس امن كتائب
القسام اعلنت ان العمليه رد سريع على
اقتحام جنين الاخير وفي وقت تشهد فيه
الضفه الغربيه توترا متصاعدا قال الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو بوتيريش انه
يتفهم مخاوف اسرائيل لكن التصعيد لا يحل
شيئا لاستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف ستتعامل
قوات الاحتلال مع عمليه
كتائب القسام المسؤوليه عنها وجاءت
النتائج كالتالي
65% وقعوا حدوث مزيدا من التصعيد بينما
صوت خمسه وثلاثون في المئه لصالح خيار
تراجع التصعيد هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على
الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل احد جنوده في
عمليه على مستوطنه كيدوميم غرب مدينه
نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه والتي اصيب فيها
احد حراس المستوطنه ايضا وقالت قوات
الاحتلال انها قتلت منفذ العمليات وفي تبن
المباشر اعلنت كتائب القسام ان عمليات
عيله وتل ابيب وكدميم تاكيد على جاهزيتها
للرد على العدوان في اي مكان في المقابل
قال وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
ان الحكومه ستسرع بناء الف ومئه وحده
استيطانيه قرب موقع الهجوم
لا يكاد يمر اقتحام اسرائيلي لمخيم او
بلده في الضفه الغربيه الا وياتي رد من
بندقيه فلسطيني او سيارته او حتى سكينه
نحو 48 ساعه فقط من انتهاء الاقتحام
الاسرائيلي لمخيم جنين يقتل جندي اسرائيلي
ويصاب حارس امن برصاص اطلقه فلسطيني عند
مستوطنه كيدومين بالضفه الغربيه ليعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي لاحقا قتله للمهاجم
ومستوطنه كيدومين بدا انشاؤها عام 75 عبر
مراحل بمصادره اسرائيل اراضيه من ثلاث قرى
هي كفر قدوم وايماتين وجيت ويسكنها الان
نحو سته الاف مستوطن اسرائيلي ما حدث في
كيدوميم يشبه الى حد كبير ما شهدته
مستوطنه عيلي في العشرين من شهر حزيران
يونيو الماضي وقتها قتل اربعه مستوطنين
وجرح اربعه اخرون بهجوم نفذه فلسطينيان
عندما مدخل المستوطنه الهجوم على مستوطنه
عيد جاء بعد يوم واحد او اقل من اقتحام
الجيش الاسرائي
ان العمليات تاخذ منحا تصاعديا كلما
تزايدت الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه وهجمات
المستوطنين كما انها كشفت عن امتلاك
المنفذين لاسلحه متطوره نسبيا مقارنه
باسلحه متواضعه استخدمت سابقا هذا عدا عن
ظهور العبوات الناسفه والالغام خلال
اقتحام مخيم جنين
بيان كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه
حماس قال ان منفذه عمليه كيدوميم اليوم هو
احمد ياسين هلال غيظان من قريه قيبه غرب
رام الله مشيرا الى ان هذه العمليه تاتي
ردا سريعا على عدوان الاحتلال وتغوله في
مخيم جنين وتدنيسه المقدسات اضاف البيان
ان العمليه جاءت لتقول للوزير الاسرائيلي
ان كتائب القسام كادت ان تطرق باب بيته من
جهتها افادت وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه ان قوات
الاحتلال اعتقلت والده وشقيقه عند حاجز
علين بعد استدعائهما من قبل المخابرات
الاسرائيليه
هذا واصيب ثلاثه فلسطينيين بالرصاص الحي
واخرون برصاص معدني مغلفا بالمطاط اضافه
لحالات اختناق خلال مواجهات بين شبان
وقوات الاحتلال في قريه
قبيه غرب رام الله بالضفه قبي عفوا غرب
رام الله بالضفه الغربيه وقد حاول الشبان
التصدي لقوات الاحتلال التي اقتحمت منزله
منفذ عمليه مستوطنه
ينضم الينا من غزه ياسر ابو هين الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بك سيد ياسر ابو
هين ما نوع التحول الذي نراه في هذه
العمليات لاسيما
الدلالات والرسائل التي حملتها هذه
العمليه في
اعتقد ان التحول الابرز في هذه العمليه هو
الاعلان المباشر لكتائب القسام مسؤوليتها
المباشره والسريعه بعد وقت قصير من
العمليه هذا يعطي مؤشر ودليل ودلائل على
ان هذه العمليه هي من تخطيط وتنفيذ مسبق
لكتائب القسام وهو ترجمه فعليه لتهديدات
قياده حركه حماس وكتائب القسام الفتره
الاخيره او مؤخرا بعد اجتياح جنين من ان
جنين لم تكون وحدها هذا ترجمته حركه حماس
في عمليه تل ابيب التي جاءت بعد اجتياح
جنين وترجمته كتائب القسام ايضا اليوم في
عمليه
كادوميم هذا الاعلان يشير الى ان الكتائب
الى ان كتائب القسام وحركه حماس تنتهج
الان او بدات تنتهج نهجا مباشرا في
الاعلان عن مسؤوليتها المباشره عن
العمليات التي تنفذ في الضفه الغربيه
وبعضها سابقا كان ينفذ دون ان عنه مباشره
حركه حماس او كتائب القسام تغريده الناطق
العسكري باسم قتال القسام ابو عبيده التي
اعاقبت البيان الرسمي والعمليه اشارت الى
عمليتين صدقتا عمليه
لم تعلن عنها كتائب القسام وبشكل بشكل
مباشر الاعلان الرسمي اليوم يعطي مؤشر ان
ان القسام لديه ما يقول وان التهديدات او
ان الوعودات التي اطلقتها قياده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الناجينيين لن تكون لوحدها وان
الضفه لن تكون مستباحه لوحدها يعطي ان
القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه لديه امكانيه
ان يضرب في كل منطقه في الضفه الغربيه
الاجتياح كان في جنين في شمال جنين والرد
جاء من جنوب الضفه الغربيه وفي قلب الكيان
الاسرائيلي في تل ابيب هذا يعطي
السيد ياسر ماذا ننتظر ما هو الاتي
باعتقادك من بعد
التبني لهذه العمليات الثلاث
اعتقد ان القادم سيكون لصالح المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واليوم عمليه كادوميم وما
اعلنته كتائب القسام من جنين اليوم يعطي
مؤشرات قويه على ما يتوفر لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بعد يوم واحد فقط من انتهاء
اجتياح جنين الذي تفاخرت به قوات الاحتلال
انها قضت على معاقل للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
ودمرت مصانع للاسلحه والعبوات المحليه
نشرت كتائب القسام في الضفه الغربيه مقطع
فيديو
يعطي صورا حديثه بتاريخ اليوم عن عوده
تصنيع هذه العبوات في جنين التي دمرت
واجتيحت هذا يعطي مؤشر ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بخير وان
امكانيات التصنيع حتى وان كانت محدوده وهي
لا تقارن بما لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه لديها لديها امكانيه ان ان تستعيد
عافيتها
ترمم قوتها وان تستمر وتستمر في ضرب قوات
الاحتلال
وتنفيذ عمليات هذا اولا اريد
لو سمحت بينما انت تتحدث الينا الى هذه
الى هذه السلسله من الاخبار العاجله التي
تظهر على شاشتنا فصائل المقاومه في جنين
وهي تعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا
تتحدث عن اننا في ظلال معركه باس جنين
نؤكد بان خيار الجهاد والمقاومه باق ما
بقي الاحتلال وتقول للعدو وقياداته انما
بعد معركه باس جنين ليس كما قبله وانها
ستواصل الاعداد والتجهيز على كافه
المستويات للتصدي للاحتلال عند كل اقتحام
واعتداء
وان على فشل الاحتلال في الوصول الى
المجاهدين والقضاء عليهم اذا تؤكد ان
الاحتلال الفاشله في اهداف عمليته ولكن
سيد ياسر بالعوده اليك
الرد الاول على التوجه لسموتريتش والقول
له بان
طيب اذا قبل ان نتابع هذه المقابله سيد
ياسر نذهب مباشره الى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
للفصائل الفلسطينيه في جنين الى هناك
للاسف يبدو ان ضد الخمسه
طيب للاسف يبدو ان هناك صعوبه في امكانيه
تلقي الاشاره من داخل مخيم جنين اعود اليك
سيد ياسر ابو هند الرد الاولي الان من
اسرائيل كان بتسريع بناء الف مستوطنه كيف
يمكن تقييم ذلك
اعتقد ان هناك اشاره مهمه في عمليه كتائب
القسام اليوم ان منفذ العمليه احمد ياسين
غيضان يسكن في قريه قبيا وهي غرب رام الله
العمليه نفذت في مستوطنه كادومين غرب
نابلس والمسافه بين قبيا واكاديميم 29
كيلو متر في هذه المسافه هناك العشرات من
المواقع الاسرائيليه والمستوطنات والشوارع
التي يتواجد عليها المستوطنون والواضح ان
القرار لدى كتائب القسام وحركه حماس ان
ينفذ ان تنفذ هذه العمليه تحديدا في مدخل
مستوطنه كادوميه وهي معقل او مسكن الوزير
المتطرف اسمه وكانت الرساله واضحه من
كتائب القسام ان حينما وجهت رسالتها ان ان
القسام كاد ان يطرق بابك هذا يعطي مؤشر ان
قسم لديه توجه بتركيز بتركيز العمليات
تركيز استهداف الجنود العسكريين لسببين
الاول هو
الاول هو ان يكون
افقاذ المستوطنين الشعور بالامن ان ان
الجندي الاسرائيلي الذي مطلوب منه ان يوفر
الحمايه والامن للمستوطنات والمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين سواء في الضفه الغربيه او
حتى في الداخل اصلا يفتقد الى الحمايه
ويفتقد الى الامن من خلال الاستهداف
المستمر من كتابه الرسام والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهذا يعطي هذا يعطي شعور
بفقدان الامن ويعيدنا في الى بدايات
انتفاضه الاقصى حينما اثبتت بعض الدراسات
والاحصائيات والتي نشرها الاعلام
الاسرائيلي ان الاستهداف المستمر للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في بدايات انتفاضه الاقصى
للجنود عمل على تعزيز حاله عدم الشعور
بالامن لدى المستوطنين ما افقد ما عمل الى
افراغ بعض المستوطنات ورغبه الرئيس
الكذب والمحلل السياسي من غزه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر
من الناصره ينضم الينا محمد مجاد للباحث
المتخصص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك
سيد محمد كيف كان وقع هذه العمليه في
اسرائيل سيما انها اتت في اعقاب العمليه
العسكريه التي نفذت في جنين وكان هدفها
القضاء على البنيه التحتيه للمقاومه هناك
يعني الحقيقه بان كل العمليه الان في عقاب
هذا الاجتياح لمخيم جنين سيكون لها وقع
كبير وصدى اكبر على المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اولا ثم على المستوى السياسي وتحديدا على
حكومه نتنياهو بنك فيروس ولذلك راينا يعني
ردود الفعل المتصاعده التي تتوعد بزياده
البناء الاستيطاني وكذلك ايضا بتصعيد
الردود العسكريه المختلفه لان هذه العمليه
العسكريه وبالبدايه اطلقت كعمليه عسكريه
واسعه النطاق ثم بعد ذلك تحدثوا عن عمليه
خاطفه محدوده وراينا في نهايه المطاف ان
هناك من قلل اكثر فاكثر من يعني حجم ومدى
هذه العمليه ببساطه لانها يعني لم تحقق
الكثير على الصعيد الاسرائيلي هكذا ايضا
يعني هناك اعترافات من بعض الجهات
السياسيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى ذلك
حتى في اطار هذه العمليه راينا عمليه
الدرس في تل ابيب وهو الامر الذي يؤكد من
جديد ايضا بان هذه العمليات العسكريه ليست
هي التي تنهي المصاعب الام نيه لدى
اسرائيل والان تاتي هذه العمليه لتؤكد من
جديد بان كل ما كان من اجتياح انما هو
عمليه سياسيه اكثر من كونه عسكريه قام بها
بنيامين نتنياهو للحصول على حاله من
الهدوء في داخل الائتلاف الحكومي تحديدا
في ظل كل هذه التهديدات المتصاعده
والتصدعات ايضا من
جهات يمنيه متطرفه في داخل هذا الائتلاف
الحكومي
التعامل مع تبني كتائب القسام لهذه
العمليه وايضا لعمليتي عيله وتل ابيب
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه على فكره يعني لم
تتعامل الجهات الاسرائيليه المختلفه ان
كان امنيا وسياسيا مع هذه يعني مع هذا
التطور من كتائب القسم ولكن يعني هناك
محاوله دائما من قبل المستوى الامني
تحديدا في اسرائيل بان يحمل المسؤوليه
لحركه حماس على ما يحدث في الضفه الغربيه
وكذلك ايضا راينا في خلال هذا اليوم بعض
الجهات التي بدات تتحرك من داخل الائتلاف
الحكومي الاسرائيلي لتقول وهذا بدفع طبعا
من الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
بان اسرائيل الان ستقوم بخطوات بناءه لدعم
السلطه الفلسطينيه يعني تقويتها وعدم
السماح بانهيارها اقتصاديا لكي تتمكن هي
بالقيام من دورها في الضفه الغربيه عامه
وفي شمال الضفه الغربيه على وجه الخصوص
هذا يعني بالضروره بان اسرائيل بطبيعه
الحال وتحديدا الجهات المتطرفه في داخل
الحكومه تواجه الان مشكلتين المشكله
الاولى بانها تحمل المسؤوليه حماس ولا
تستطيع القيام بالرد على حركه حماس في
قطاع غزه حيث يمكن لاسرائيل ان ترد بالفعل
يعني على حركه حماس ومن جانب اخر يعني هي
لا تستطيع او لا تريد بالفعل دعم السلطه
الفلسطينيه لان كل هذه الجهات المتطرفه
يعني تحقد على كل شيء فلسطيني حتى على
السلطه الفلسطينيه فهذا الامر بطبيعه
الحال يزيد من تعقيد المشهد الاسرائيلي في
داخل الائتلاف الحكومي في داخل المشهد
السياسي لان حتى سياسه نتنياهو التي على
الاقل تحاول دائما ان تراوح بين كل
الخيارات الصعبه باتت اصعب الان بسبب هذا
التطرف القائم بسبب كل هذا الاستقطاب يعني
هذا الاعتراف الحكومي وتحديدا
وان يرى الدم الفلسطيني يمكن ان يتصرف في
الضفه الغربيه امام هذا المازق الذي شرحته
لنا
على فكره يعني هذا اصعب وهذا يصعب اكثر
على اليمين وحقيقه يعني هناك عجز كبير جدا
من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه لابد من
الاشاره الى ذلك هذه ليست يعني شعارات نحن
نسمع ذلك يوميا ونراه على فكره ايضا من كل
التصريحات التي تسمع من قبل قاده
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه وفي شمال
الضفه الغربيه ذلك وصل الى ان يعني
المستوطنين يهاجمون قاده الجيش يعني ليس
فقط لفظا انما فعلا يطردونهم من بيوت
العزاء هناك غضب واحتقان كبير جدا يعني في
قاعده المستوطنين او دعينا نقول في جمهور
المستوطنين في شمال الضفه الغربيه الذين
يتعرضون لكل هذه المخاطر الذين لا يشعرون
بالامان وهم يفرغون كل هذه الطاقه على
الجيش الاسرائيلي على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ولذلك نرى بان كل هذا الضغط يولد الانفجار
هذا الاجتياح في جنين هو بطبيعه الحال
نتيجه ضغط سياسي ونتيجه ضغط لا يعرفون كيف
يتعاملون معه فيخرج بهذه الطريقه شكرا
الاسرائيليه ضيفنا من النصر
في جنين تواصلوا تواقم المؤسسات الخدميه
المحليه والدفاع المدنيه الفلسطيني في
مخيم جنين اعمال ترميم وازاله اثار ما
خلفته اله الحرب الاسرائيليه فقد شهدت
شوارع وازقه المخيم حركه نشيطه للاليات
لرفع مخلفات العمليه العسكريه الاخيره
ياتي ذلك في وقت ما تزال فيه العائلات
تعود الى بيوتها وتلملم ما تبقى من
ممتلكاتها
من بيوت طالها القصف ورصاص الاحتلال في حي
جره الذهب بمخيم جنين ابو عبيده مرعي هجر
قصرا مع عائلته من بيته خلال العمليه
العسكريه في المخيم لكنه عاد ليجده مخترقا
بفعل القصف الاسرائيلي
احنا قاعدين وامين بالبيت وما شاء الله
عنا
شفنا الناس قاعده بتطلع من البيت
كنا طلعنا معهم رجعت لقيت البيت مثل ما
انت شايف وانا راجع على البيت اليوم قاعد
بعزل بالبيت على اساس انام فيه لاني انا
ما بقدر انام غير ببيتي المؤسسات الطبيه
في المخيم لم تسلم هي ايضا من نيران
الاحتلال مستشفى جنين الحكوميه تعرضت
مرافقه للاستهداف بقنابل الغاز والرصاص
مرات عده وهو ما زاد من خطوره عمل طواقمه
وهدد حياه المرضى يعني كان هناك صعوبه
كبيره في العمل داخل المستشفى في لحظات
معينه تجد قسم الطوارئ قد فرغ من جميع
الطاقم الطبي بسبب دخول الغازات المصريه
للدموع ولم يعني وحدث عده مرات
المرضى تم نقلهم خارج قسم الطوارئ وتم
علاجهم على الاربعه في الممرات يعني يعني
حقيقه شكل الوضع شكل الوضع خطير جدا
وفي شوارع وازقه المخيم تواصل طواقب
المؤسسات الرسميه والمحليه اعمال تنظيف
وازاله مخلفات العمليه العسكريه واثار
دمارها لليوم الثاني على التوالي فالعمليه
العسكريه دمرت البنيه التحتيه لشبكات
المياه والكهرباء والاتصالات ناهيك عن
الحاق الضرر بمئات المنازل والمركبات كليا
او جزئيا
هو مشهد يتكرر عقب كل عمليه اسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين دمار وخراب وجهود مضنيه لمحو
اثار العدوان
يقابلهما صمود وتمسك بالحق في المقاومه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره من مخيم الجنين
فلسطين
قالت كتيبه جنين اتابع لسرايا القدس ان
جهاز الامن الوقائي ما زال يعتقل اثنين من
عناصرها معتبره الامر طعن من الخلف وقالت
الكتيبه في بيان ان عنصريها كان في
طريقهما لمسانده اخوانهما في مخيم جنين
وتم اعتقالهما والاعتداء عليهما وحملت
الكتيبه السلطه الفلسطينيه مسؤوليه حياه
المقاومين الاثنين المضربين عن الطعام في
سجونها وصفت الكتيبه الاعتقال السياسي بحق
عنصريها بانه وصمه عار داعيه قياده فتح
الى تحمل مسؤوليتها
وفي مقابله اجريتها قبل الحصاد مع
المندوبه البريطانيه في مجلس الامن
السفيره باربرا ودوارد سالتها عن الموقف
البريطاني من التطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه كما تطرقنا لملفات اخرى تتعلق
بمباحثات مجلس الامن بخصوص الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران
شكرا جزيلا على الترحيب الحار وعلى الدعوه
لقد تعبانه الاحداث عن كتب في جنين ووزير
الخارجيه البريطاني تحدث مع وزير الخارجيه
كوهن يوم امس لتجديد على موقف البريطاني
حول الاستيطان غير القانوني باضافه الى
اهميه
القيام بالعمليات من ضمن القوانين الدوليه
وتحدث ايضا مع رئيس مجلس تيار الفلسطينيه
للتشديد على الامل للعوده الى المفاوضات
والامل للعمل للوصول الى حل الدولتين ونحن
نتابع عن كثب الاحداث سوف يكون لدينا يوم
غد في بعض الظهر جلسه لمجلس الامن بشان
هذه الاحداث
هل هذه العمليه الدعوات والانتظارات
البريطانيه منها لاسيما في موضوع تحييد
المدنيين وعدم استخدام القوه المفرطه
اخبرنا عن القلق عدد
الوفيات على القتلى والجرحى اود ان اتقدم
بالتعازي لكل الاسر اسر الضحايا واتمنى
التعافي السريع للجرحى وعبرنا عن قلقنا
ازاء الضرر الذي لحق بالبنى التحتيه
المدنيه في هذه العمليه لدينا قلق هذا
الموضوع وسوف نتناقش بهذا الموضوع بشكل
موسع في جلسه مجلس الامن يوم غد بعد الظهر
لكن بهذا النهج الذي تتبعه اسرائيل ضد
الفلسطينيين هذا النهج من العمليات
العسكريه ضد الفلسطينيين بموازات استمرار
الاحتلال بموازاه الانسداد في افق
المفاوضات بموازات تشريع الاستيطان
والهجمات على القرى الفلسطينيه
في العنف وكما سبق واسفت وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه تحدث مع وزير الخارجي الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي
على موقفنا بالنسبه الى توسيع الاستيطان
غير القانوني وحث قوات الدفاع الاسرائيليه
على عمل من ضمن القوانين الدوليه كل هذه
الامور هي مخاوف عبر عنها وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه وتحدث مع وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي وايضا تواصل مع رئيس مجلس
الوزراء الفلسطينيه اشتيا لتشديد على
اماله بالعوده الى المفاوضات لانه فقط من
خلال المفاوضات يمكننا ان نتوصل الى حل
الدولتين وهو ما نعمل من اجله وهل لدى
بريطانيا اي تصور لتجاوز هذا الانسداد
من الواضح ان هناك عراقيل على الطريق
ولكننا احب تشجعنا
بالاجتماع في العقبه وفي شرم ونامل ان
يكون هناك اطار او يشكل اطارا للطرفين
العوده الى طاوله المفوضات للتفاوض بشان
حل الدولتين وهو ما دعمناه بشكل متسق
لفتره طويله
كرئتين واحد وثلا
الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران
من الذي يتحمل مسؤوليه الفشل باعتقادكم في
العوده الى هذا الاتفاق
لقد انتهى اجتماع مجلس الامن الدولي حول
عدم الانتشار والنظر في قرار
22.31 وحاله خطر في العمل الشامله
المشتركه لدينا قلق بالغ بكل حقيقه
بالنسبه الى استمرار انشطه ايران التوسعيه
في برنامجها النووي هي قادره على تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه
83.7%
والمطلوب هو 90% للوصول الى سلاح النووي
بالاضافه الى ذلك لدى ايران مخزون من
اليورانيوم المخصب اكثر بثلاثه مرات من ما
هي بحاجه اليه للقنبله النوويه بالاضافه
الى ذلك قامت باختباراتي صواريخ قادره على
حمل رؤوس حربيه ول
من
اجهزه طرد المركزي الكبيره وبالتالي هذا
يعني ان ايران لا تعمل وفقا لبرنامج نووي
مدني وهو متفق عليه في الاتفاق وبالتالي
نامل انه في هذه الاشهر المتبقيه من خطه
العمل الشامل المشتركه ان تعود ايران
للقبول
بالعرض للعمل على وصولي الى الازدهار
والسلام للشعب الايراني
كيف ما هو التصور في هذا الاطار باستثناء
غير العوده عوده جميع الاطراف الى الاتفاق
النووي الايراني
تتذكرون انه في شهر اب اغسطس الماضي كان
هناك مقترح للعوده الى خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه وكان سمح لايران ولكل الفرقاء
الاخرين العوده الى الطاوله لقد تعاملنا
بكد مذاك لمحاوله اقناع ايران للعوده الى
الاتفاق ولكن كما صدق واستلفت ايران
استمرت بتخصيب اليورانيوم وتخزين
اليورانيوم المخصب واختبارات
الصاروخيه القادره على حمل رؤوس نوويه هذه
الانشطه المزعزعه على الاستقرار والتي
تنشر سفك الدماء في المنطقه تستمر
بالاضافه الى التهديدات الايرانيه في
المملكه المتحده لذلك لدينا مخاوف بالغه
ازاء هذه المواقف الايرانيه المزعزعه
للاستقرار ليس فقط في المنطقه بل في كل
ارجاء العالم
السيده كيف ستتعاملون مع التصويت على اليه
ادخال المساعدات الى مناطق الشمال السوري
في المرحله المقبله خصوصا في ظل الضغوط
الروسيه
بادخالها عبر المعابر التابعه للنظام
بكل صراحه
عبرنا عن سخطنا ازاء الضغط الذي تحاول
روسيا ان تفرضه لاغلاق الممرات الانسانيه
لقد قلت في الجنوب الشرق تركيا على الحدود
مع سوريا منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وفكرت ورايت
وضع
والحاجه الحاجات الانسانيه اكثر من اربعه
مليون شخص في هذه المنطقه من سوريا هم
بحاجه ملحه الى المساعدات الانسانيه من
طعام وغذاء وبطانيات
وادويه طبعا الوضع يتفاقم
اصبح اسوا بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وتركيا تحصل على دعما انسانيه من الامم
المتحده للتعامل مع هذه الماساه وتابعتها
اذا وهذا ما استمعت اليه في المنطقه نحن
بحاجه الى على الاقل ثلاثه مرات
للمساعدات الانسانيه لكي تتمكن وكالات
الامم المتحده والوكالات الانسانيه من
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للناس الذين هم
بامس الحاجه اليها وكما تفضلتي ان الروس
يحاولون ان يعطلوا هذه الجهود لاسباب
سياسيه ويعرقلون الوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه ويحولها الى ورقه سياسيه ونود
ان نتاكد من فتح المعابر لتامين المساعدات
الانسانيه
ونحن نحاول ان نعيد فتح الممرات يوم
الاثنين شكرا لك برا المندوبه البريطانيه
في مجلس الامن الدولي شكرا على هذه
المقابله معنا
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفري
عن نظام جديد للعقوبات ضد ايران من شانه
ان يوسع صلاحيات بريطانيا لفرض مزيد من
العقوبات على كيانات وافراد لمواجهه ما
وصفه بالانشطه العدائيه والمزعزعه
للاستقرار في المملكه المتحده وفي العالم
اليوم اعلن مزيدا من الاجراءات من حزمه
ادوات افضل عدم استخدامها لكن قرار
استخدامها من عدمه يبقى بين يدين نظام
الايراني نفسه حيث نضعوا نظاما جديدا
للعقوبات الايرانيه وسيكون اول نظام مستقل
من نوعه لبريطانيا منذ الخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي وسيعطينا صلاحيات جديده ومعززه
لمواجهه انشطه ايران العدائيه المزعزعه
للاستقرار في المملكه المتحده وحول العالم
وسيسمح لنا بتجميد الاصول وفرض حظر سفر
على مزيد من صانعي القرارات في ايران
ووكلاء النظامي
اعلنت الخارجيه الايرانيه استدعاء القائمه
باعمال سفاره البريطانيه بطهران على خلفيه
ما وصفته بتصريحات هدامه قالت انها صدرت
عن مسؤولين بريطانيين والتدخل في شؤون
ايران الداخليه وقالت الخارجيه الايرانيه
انها ابلغت القائمه باعمال السفاره
البريطانيه ان مواقف لندن الاخيره
والعقوبات الجديده التي فرضتها على طهران
غير قانونيه ومدانا اضافت انما وصفته
بسياسه البريطانيه الهدامه جهه طهران
مرفوضه وستواجه برد مماثل ومتناسب ومؤثرا
من قبل ايران كما ان طهران انتقدت بشده
دعوه بريطانيا اوكرانيا للمشاركه في
اجتماع مجلس الامن الدولي لمناقشه تطبيق
الاتفاق النووي يذكر ان بريطانيا فرضت
عقوبات على 13 شخصيه وكيانا ايرانيا بتهمه
انتهاك حقوق الانسان
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
عن قيام الحرس الثوري الايراني بمصادره
سفينه بالقوه اثناء عبورها المياه الدوليه
في الخليج وقال المتحدث باسم البحريه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
الى سفينه كانت على الارجح ضالعه في تهريب
النفط الايراني اضاف المتحدث ان القوات
البحريه الامريكيه نشرت قطعا بحريه
لمراقبه الموقف عن كسب لكنها قررت ان
الظروف المحيطه بالحادثه لا تستدعي تدخلها
هذا ونقل مراسل الجزيره في البنتاجون عن
مسؤول امريكي قوله ان البحريه الامريكيه
في الشرق الاوسط لم تتدخل للحينوله دون
مصادره السفينه بعد توصلها الى خلاصه انها
ضالعه في انشطه غير مشروعه تتعلق بتهريب
النفط
بدات وزيره الخزانات الامريكيه جانتيالين
زياره الى الصين تتصدر ملفات القيود
المفروضه على الصادرات المنتجات
التكنولوجيه الصينيه وتدابير المنافسه
وكانت اداره بايدن فرضت العام الماضي
قيودا على تصدير اشباه الموصلات ومكونات
التكنولوجيا الامريكيه الى الصين وقبل ذلك
كانت قد ابقت على رسوم الجمركيه فرضها
ترامب على منتجات منتجات تصدرها الصين الى
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه كان زيدان ان
التعديلات التي اقرتها السويد لمكافحه
الارهاب لا معنى لها اذا استمر نشاط حزب
العمال الكردستاني على اراضيها جاءت
تصريحات فيدان بعد اجتماع في بروكسل مع
نظريه السويدي والفنلندي وامين عام حلف
النيتو من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه
السويدي ان بلاده تتطلع الى قرار ايجابي
الاسبوع المقبل بشان عضويه النيتو
انتظار السويد على اعتاب النيتو قد لا
يطول اكثر فقبل قمه الحلف المرتقبه خلال
اقل من اسبوع تتعزز المؤشرات على ان عضويه
ستوكهولم في النادي الاطلسي باتت اقرب من
اي وقت مضى هذا اللقاء رفيع المستوى في
مقر الناتو بروكسل بين وفود تركيا والسويد
وفنلندا برعايه يمين عام الحلف انتهى
ايجابيا لكن دون ان يرقى الامر تماما الى
ضوء اخضر تركي
من ان التعديلات الدستوريه لا تكفي لمنع
العنف على ارض الواقع علينا ان نتاكد ان
السويد اوفت بتعهداتها التي قطعتها على
نفسها وايضا على السويد ان لا تسمح
بتصرفات الاستفزازيه على اراضيها فلا
يمكننا التسامح مع حرق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف هناك اما وزير الخارجيه السويدي
فبدا اكثر تفاؤلا من نظيره التركي
سيلتقي الرئيس التركي اردوغان ورئيس
الوزراء السويدي كريستال بعضهما البعض
سيكون هذا اجتماعا مهما للغايه العمليه
مستمره ونحن بالطبع نعمل بشكل مكثف للغايه
في الايام المقبله حتى نتمكن من الانضمام
الى النيتو نامل ونتطلع الى قرار ايجابي
الاسبوع المقبل وهذا بالطبع قرار تركي في
النهايه
لقاء الرئيس التركي مع رئيس وزراء السويد
اكده ايضا الامين العام للنيتو الذي رعى
الاجتماع معتبرا ان عضويه السويد باتت في
متناول اليد
ستحقق عضويه السويد فوائد عسكريه كبيره
للحلف باكمله كما سيسمح انضمامها الينا
بالتخطيط للدفاع عن منطقه القطب الشمالي
ومنطقه البلطيق باكملها كوحده واحده ان
عضويه السويد في النيتو ستجعلنا جميعا
اقوى واكثر
الاجتماع الثلاثي تزامن مع رساله ايجابيه
من ستوكهولم الى انقره حيث قضت محكمه
سويديه بالسجن اربع سنوات ونصف السنه على
تركي متهم بالعمل لصالح حزب العمال
الكردستاني وسوف يتم ترحيله الى تركيا بعد
قضاء فتره عقوبته
اعتراضات تركيا على انضمام السويد للنيتو
بدات منذ اكثر من عام على خلفيه مطالبتها
عناصر متهمه بالانتماء لمنظمات تصنفه
وانقر ارهابيه كحزب العمال الكردستاني
وحركه الخدمه التي يقودها فتح الله جولان
كما تدعوها الى اغلاق اي مؤسسات او مقرات
تابعه لتلك المنظمات مع ضروره ادخال
تعديلات على القوانين السويديه لمكافحه
الارهاب فضلا عن رفع الحظر الذي تفرضه
ستوكهولم على مبيعات الاسلحه الى تركيا
اقرت انقر بان بعض تلك المطالب شرعت
السويد في الايفاء
بقرارات ايجابيه فيما يتعلق بهذا الامر
[موسيقى]
انسان اجتماع اليوم كان جيدا ومما قراته
في الصحافه ولكن ما زل الان ننتظر اجتماع
يوم الاثنين بين الرئيس التركي اردوغان
ورئيس الوزراء السويد
ثم طبعا مع الامين العام
حيث سيناقشان بقايا المصادر الخوف والقلق
لدى براعه القلق لدى تركيا فيما يتعلق
بتلبيه كل الشروط والمتطلبات لوضعتها
تركيا لتقوى وافق على انضمامها الى النيتو
على هذا طلبهم هذا
واننا
وما هو المتوقع من هذا الاجتماع بالنظر
الى وضوح الموقف التركي والحديث السويدي
عن انه جرب تلبيه معظم المطالب رغم ان
تركيا تقول ان هذا ليس هو الوضع والحال
نعم
نحن
سمعنا بان هناك نقاشات
قالها او اراء طرحها جانب التركي بانهم
يودون التاكد من التنفيذ كل القرارات
والقوانين المناهضه للارهاب التي
تبنتها السويد مؤخرا التطبيقها في الاول
مشار يونيو حزيران وايضا
شاهدنا
اراء من السويد والامين العام النيتو
بالقول بان تسويت قد اوفت بكل التزاماتها
ووافقت على كل الشروط وبالتالي فهي مستعده
للجائزه لانضمام الى النيتو ولكن طبعا
لسنا متاكدين مئه بالمئه ما الذي سيحصل
يوم الاثنين
وهل ان القيادتين سيتوصلان الى اتفاق حول
انضمام السويد ولكن ما نعرفه بشكل مؤكد هو
ان تصبح
تصلح السويد العضو الثاني والثلاثين في
النيتو يعزز هذا التحالف وهذا ايضا مفيد
لتركيا لكن ماذا لو فشلت هذه المحاوله
يعني ما تاثيرها الان على النيتو وعلى هذه
المواجهه بين الغرب وروسيا
ماسك لا قلنا كاخفاقه
في عمليه مستمره
لانهاء مساله التصديق على انضمام
السويد الى النيتو وهذا الامر قد طلب وقتا
ولكن في نهايه المطاف سيتحقق ذلك ويحصل
وعند بعد انهاء كل المخاوف والقلق التركي
واستطيع القول انه حتى في الوقت الحالي في
هذه المرحله السويد
لديها امكانيه الدخول في كل مناقشات
سياسيه داخل المنظمه الناتو وكل التمارين
والمناورات العسكريه والتعاون العسكري مع
التحالف هذا وبالتالي في السويد
بشكل ما تعتبر انها لديها مشاركه في كل
اعمال ونشاطاتها هذا التحالف اي النيتو
وعندما
وعندما تقوم
تركيا بمصادقه على الانضمام انا داخل
السويس تروح عضما رسميا في النيتو وانذاك
فان الماده الخمسه في النيتو التي تعلق
بالدفاع المشترك والجمعي سيتطبق على
السويد ايضا ولكن الدنيا ذلك سيكون لدينا
التزام من قبل المملكه المتحده والولايات
المتحده والدول النيتوبل الدفاع عن السويد
شكرا لك دكتوره
الباحثه الامنيه والدفاعيه السابقه في
الجمعيه البرلمانيه لحلف الناتو والباحثه
في مركز مارتنز للدراسات ضيفتنا من بروكسل
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلنت
السلطات مقتل اربعه اشخاص واصابه ثلاثه
وثلاثين في هجوم صاروخي روسي استهدف مدينه
الفيف غربيه البلاد وكان حاكم منطقه الفيف
قال ان المدينه تعرضت لهجوم من صباح اليوم
ادى لسقوط لسقوط جرحى وتضرر 35 مبنى
وتدمير احدى منشات البنيه التحتيه وقد
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه عن الرئيس
الاوكراني
انه سيكون هناك رد ملموس على الهجوم
الصاروخيه الروسي على الفيف من جانبها
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها دمرت
سكنات عسكريه كان بها نحو 800 من المرتزقه
الاجانب والقوات الاوكرانيه في الفيف
مشيره الى انه كان بها معدات عسكريه غربيه
[موسيقى]
في روسيا قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان موسكو لا تتعقب قائد قوات فاجنر
اضاف بيسكوف ان الاتفاق مع قائد فاغنر
الذي تم بوساطه من الرئيس البيلاروسي لا
يزال قائما
من ناحيته قال الامين العام للنيتو ان قله
قليله من قوات فاجنر انتقلت الى بيلاروسيا
لافتا الى ان هناك من ظل منها في اوكرانيا
لكن ليس في الخطوط الاماميه واوضح ان
النيتو تابع قيام بيلاروسيا بتحضيرات
لاستقبال قوات فاجنر على اراضيها لكن
كثيرا من هذه القوات لم تدخل بيلاروسيا
وقال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن تواصل مراقبه
مجموعه كسب وكان الرئيس البالروسي الكسندر
لوكاشينكو قد قال ان قوات فاجنر لم تنتقل
حتى الان الى بيلاروسيا مشيرا الى ان
الامر يعود الى الرئيس بوتين وقاده كما
اشار الى ان مؤسس شركه فاجنر ما زال في
روسيا مراسلنا
رصد المواقع التي يعتقد انها انها تتمركز
فيها قوات فاجنر في بيلاروسيا على ضوء
التسويه التي تمت عقب محاوله التمرد
العسكري الشهر الماضي
داخل هذه الغابات على اطراف قريه تشيل
التي تبعد نحو 150 كيلومترا عن ميسك توجد
بقايا قاعده عسكريه
قاعده بقيت مهجوره الى اشتهرت مجددا عقب
اعلان انتقال قوات فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا
مواقع غربيه وعسكريه روسيه نشرت صور اقمار
صناعيه وفوتوغرافيه لما قيل انه معسكر
يجري انشاؤه في هذه القاعده
خصوصا لقوات فاجنر القادمه من روسيا اثر
محاوله التمرد العسكري الشهر الماضي
انتقال قوات فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا وتمركزها
في قواعد ليست بعيده عن الحدود الاوكرانيه
يطرحان تكهنات كثيره بشان مستقبلها ودورها
في هذا البلد
رئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكيشنكا حاول
التبديد بعض الغموض بشان وجود فاجنر في
بلاده
خلال لقاء بصحفيين اجانب ان بلاده لن تكون
منطلقا لاي تدخل عسكري ضد احد مهما كانت
صيغته
حتى اليوم مساله اعاده تمركز قوات فاغنر
ونشرها في بيلاروسيا لم تعالج نهائيا قدوم
فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا مرتبط بقرار الرئيس
الروسي وقاده فاجنر نحن لم نعتدي على احد
واذا تعرضنا للعدوان فسنرد في حال ظهرت
راجنر في بيلاروسيا فانها ستدافع عن بلدنا
على غرار الجيش البيلاروسي
رئيس البيلاروسيه اعتبر كذلك ان من
الضروري الحفاظ على قوه فاجنر لحتفيتها
العسكريه
والاستفاده من خبرتها القتاليه في صفوف
القوات المسلحه البيلاروسيه
احد هنا في بيلاروسيا لشركه فاجنر او
غيرها بان تصبح قوه سياسيه عسكريه كما
كانت في روسيا لم يحسم الجدل بعد بشان
مستقبل شركه فاقدر لا سيما ما يتعلق
بنشاطها خارج روسيا لكن من المؤكد ان
مينسك ستضع اطرا واضحه وحاسمه كما قال
لوكاشنكا تضبط فيها وجود هذه القوه
العسكريه في المشهد السياسي للبلاد
زورج الجزيره بيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
كان وليد الصدفه فبعيدا عن بداياته الاولى
ومراهقته والكثير من الاحداث في حياته
تعرف الرجل على الرئيس الروسي الحليف
لاديمير بوتين حينما كان الاخير نائبا
لعمده في احد المطاعم التابعه لبريغوجي
نفسه اعجب به بوتين ونمت العلاقه الى ان
اصبح رئيسا للبلاد فاوكلت
مهمه اطعام الجيش في عطاء فتح له الكثير
من الابواب تسارعت الخطه نحو مزيد من
النفوذ والمهمات التي لم يكشف الكثير منها
لكن كشف مشروع فاجنر بل كشف مشروع فاغنر
كان حتميا لحضور بريجوجند البارز خلال
مرحله التاسيس ثم قيادتها اثناء الحرب في
اوكرانيا قبل بدء الحرب كشفت الولايات
المتحده دورا اخر له بالوقوف خلف نشر
معلومات مضلله عبر الانترنت قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في عام 2016
لكن اسئله ملحه عن مستقبل شركه فاجنر تظل
ماثله تقدر بعض اجهزه المخابرات الغربيه
اعداد جنودها باكثر من 50 الفا وتتهم
المجموعه بارسال مسلحها الى عده دول في
امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا كما تم تسجيل
نشاطات لفادينر في سوريا منذ عام 2016
ينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من لندن
الدكتور كير جويلز كبير المحللين في
المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدوليه تشادنهاوس
مرحبا بك دكتور كير جويلز ماذا فهمت من
كلام الرئيس البيلاروسي عن ان ابريجوجن لا
يزال او بريكوجين موجود في داخل روسيا ولم
ياتي الى بيلاروسيا بحسب الاتفاق الذي على
اساسه توقف تمرد فاغنر
اتحدث عن وضع يصعب فيه ان نعرف ماذا يحصل
لانه ما من شيء منطقي وما من مصدر موثوق
للمعلومات وذلك بما فيه الرئيس لقد نعرف
ماهيه الاتفاق وما اذا كان قد خرق طيب
ولكن ايضا يعني
نتعامل مع المعلومات التي لدينا يقول
لوكاشينكو ان لم ياتي الى منسك ومن ثم
يقول الكرمله انه غير معني بالبحث عن ايضا
ماذا يفهم من هذا الامر
هذا يتوقف على ما تم الاتفاق بشانه بين
ولكن بغض النظر عن ذلك نحن نتحدث عن سابقه
خطره للسلطه في روسيا لان سمح له بعد تحدي
الدوله ان يبقى على قيد الحياه ولا ربما
العوده الى
يجمع 110 مليون دولار باموال النقديه
واسلحه اذا هذا تحد للدوله وهذه السابقه
ان يبقى على قيد الحياه تحدي للدوله يقول
الكريم لانه غير معني بمصيره يقول انه
ملتزم باتفاق انهاء التمرد ولكن ايضا في
الاعلام الرسمي الروسي نرى هذا يعني
الانقضاض على صوره بريجوجل بعكس ما كان
يحصل قبل التمرد ايضا كيف يمكن قراءه هذا
الامر
هذا بالضبط صحيح وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
تلعب دورا اساسيا لقد قلبت الطاوله على
عوضا عن ان يكون احد ابطال الحرب في
اوكرانيا الان هو الرجل الشرير هو الذي
السارق الذي يستفيد من الدوله الروسيه
وبالضبط هذا ما تريده الدوله الروسيه ان
يفكر الشعب بهذه الطريقه ولكن هذا ليس
بالضروره ان يترجم افعالا ضد بريغوجين
بشكل مباشر هناك حمله ضد بروجن ولكن هذا
لا يعني انه بالضروره بخطر ماذا عن
مقاتليه فاجنر وايضا يتحدث لوكاشينكو عن
ان الكثير منهم ما زال في داخل اوكرانيا
ما مصير هؤلاء باعتقادك باختصار لو سمحت
ده سؤال مفتوح كذلك لان
بيلاروسيا لا يمكنها ان تتلقى كل
المقاتلين نحن نتحدث عن مقاتلين مدججين
بالسلاح وغير السعداء بالنتيجه وهذا سوف
يشكل تحديا لروسيا وبلاروسيا وبالتالي
السؤال المفتوح بالنسبه الى التطورات شكرا
لك
في المعهد الملكي لشؤون الدوليه تشاظم
هاوس ضيفنا من لندن
وبهذا مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]